some princesses are born into royalty
and others marry into it but whatever
their story may be we can all agree that
every single Disney princess deserves
her current status watch until the end
to find out which Disney character
married into a royal family without ever
knowing it now let's find out which
Disney princesses were born into royalty
and which ones married into it
Snow White Snow White was born into a
royal family but her world was quickly
shattered when her mother passed away
and her father remarried despite coming
off as a sweet stepmother at first the
Evil Queen quickly showed her true
colors after Snow White's father
mysteriously perished obsessed with
beauty and being the fairest one of all
the Evil Queen did the unthinkable and
sent a huntsman
to murder her stepdaughter however her
plan failed when the Huntsman had a
change of heart
Snow White fled her Kingdom to stay
alive but the royal wouldn't stay in the
dark for long her beautiful voice found
its way into a Prince's years causing
him to fall deeply in love with her
despite feeling the same way
Snow White chose to be cautious and fled
the Prince had no clue that Snow White
was a princess herself which is what
makes them such an ideal match by the
end of the film Snow White and the
prince marry turning her into a princess
by birth and marriage alike so in other
words Snow White is as royal as a person
can get Cinderella now let's switch our
focus to a princess who claimed her
title through marriage alone Cinderella
might be the daughter of an aristocrat
but that doesn't exactly make her a
royal match luckily for her Prince
Charming couldn't find the girl worth
marrying which caused the king to
broaden his search for a future
daughter-in-law although many royal
families refused to taint their
bloodline with unworthy matches the king
was desperate to see his son get married
so he let his son pick his own bride
despite being invited to the royal ball
Cinderella was tricked into staying home
but luckily for her she had a fairy
godmother on her side
by the end of the film Cinderella
marries into the royal family making her
a princess by matrimony
don't they make the cutest couple
rora aurora is the third disney princess
to join the lineup and much like Snow
White
she's a double whammy the evil
Maleficent placed a curse on Aurora the
day she was born
which led her to fall into a deep
slumber on her 16th birthday but if that
wasn't bad enough this curse also put
her entire kingdom to sleep as well
Princess Aurora is the daughter of King
Stefan which makes her a royal by birth
and if things had gone the way
Maleficent had intended them to Aurora
would have never had the chance to
further her royal bloodline
however Prince Phillip eventually
stumbled across the frozen Kingdom and
broke the spell with love's true kiss
after the spell was broken and
Livelihood returned to the kingdom
Aurora and Phillip were married
making Aurora Princess by birth and
marriage so there you have it
Aurora couldn't be more royal Ariel
Ariel is King Triton and Queen Athena's
youngest and feisty his daughter despite
being born into a royal bloodline area
was willing to give up everything for a
pair of legs so she did just that all
Princess Ariel wanted was to go on
adventures and learn about the world
above the sea but going to the surface
was forbidden however listening to the
rules was never Ariel's Forte one day
the little princess fell in love with a
sailor who just so happened to be a
prince and by the end of the film she
was finally able to get him to love her
in return so if anyone ever asks you
which Disney Princess stands out above
the rest you can answer Ariel with total
confidence after all she's a royal
whether she's below or above sea level
Tiana Tiana might looked like she was
born into royalty but this couldn't be
further from the truth
in fact Tiana is one of the few Disney
Princesses who becomes royal by marriage
alone her mother was a dressmaker and
her father a soldier which caused her to
know the meaning of hard work all Tiana
ever wanted was to open up her own
restaurant but life got in the way one
day she came face-to-face with a frog
and agreed to kiss him despite her
better judgment
one kiss unless you beg for more turn
into a frog was the least thank Tiana
expected but somehow changing forms
taught her the most valuable lesson of
all before Tiana knew what was happening
the princess to be started to fall for
Prince Naveen so much so that she chose
to tie the knot after sealing the deal
and kissing her prince she and Prince
Naveen turned back into their human
forms which allowed Siana to pursue her
dreams on royal grounds
Mulan when it comes down to it Mulan is
one of the only Disney princesses whose
rural status can't be justified she's
the daughter of the Honorable basu who
happens to be an old warrior her
bloodline is the furthest thing from
royal however she still referred to as a
princess while some people think that
her marriage to captain lee shang is
what turned her into a royal this is
also Faust after all li Shang is the son
of a captain not a king so what makes
Mulan a princess
well according to Disney it's her act of
heroism Mulan's actions brought so much
honor to her family that she was
instantly deemed a princess although she
might be included in the Disney princess
lineup
Milan's background sticks out like a
sore thumb and we wouldn't have her any
other way
Pocahontas Pocahontas is a kind and
open-minded Disney Princess who never
fails to seize the day she's the
daughter of Chief Powhatan making her a
Disney princess by burn despite being
warned to stay away from the foreign
intruders
Pocahontas disregards her father's
commands and spies on the strange men
who've just landed on her father's
Shores after falling in love with
Captain John Smith Pocahontas realizes
that her tribe and John's men aren't so
different after all sadly this doesn't
stop history from occurring although
Pocahontas and John Smith don't end up
getting married this doesn't make her
any less royal after all John Smith
wasn't the prince to begin with
despite coming from very different
worlds Pocahontas manages to convince
her father to spare John's life
my daughter speaks with the wisdom
beyond her year and while their last
goodbyes as somewhat of a tearjerker
John knows that the princess will always
be with him so there you have it
Pocahontas is a natural-born princess
through and through vanellope
vanellope von schweetz might be hard to
deal with at times but she has her
reasons she's a rough and tough
character who belongs to the wreck-it
ralph franchise but she's also much more
than a secondary character like most
Disney Princesses Penelope's story
begins when a big and courageous man
stumbles into her plotline I know all
vanilla pee ever wanted was to race
sadly King candy forbade her to enter
contests due to her glitch but instead
of giving up vanellope did everything
she could to enter a race and to win it
and did she ever by the end of the film
it's revealed that vanellope is actually
a long-lost princess who's had her
memory erased princess Penelope is a
natural-born royal and while she may be
too young to get married now she might
end up marrying into a royal family when
she comes of age but whether she does
this or not the princess will always be
a princess in our books Sophia she may
not be an official Disney Princess but
she sure is worth the mention Sophia is
the protagonist of the Disney Junior
series Sofia the first and she's doing
everything she can to become a royal
like her theme song explains the young
princess used to be nothing more than a
peasant that is until her mother fell in
love with the king of enchancia before
she knew what was going on
Sophia was crowned as a princess and
forced to learn the ropes
with the help of her fellow Disney
Princesses Sophia learned how to take on
the world however she is a princess by
marriage and marriage alone and if her
mother hadn't married the king she would
still be a shoemakers daughter it was a
perfect fit and so were they do you guys
think that Sophia should become an
official Disney Princess let us know
what your thoughts are in the comments
below Merida there is nothing more
important than freedom which is why
Merida chose to do everything in her
power to remain an unmarried princess
firstborn descendant of plant despite
being old enough to marry into a royal
family Merida hated the idea of becoming
someone's wife so she did everything she
could to remain single Princess Merida
is the firstborn daughter to Queen
Eleanor and King Fergus making her a
natural-born princess and while the
kingdom of dunbroch expects her to marry
another royal and eventually further her
bloodline she'd rather give her status
up than play by the rules
Merida is one of the first Disney
princesses to show zero interest in
falling in love which is why she's a gem
by the end of the film Merida's mother
accepts the fact that her daughter is
unique and wonderful in her own way
changed despite refusing to get married
Merida still a royal by birth Elsa
there's no doubt in our minds that Elsa
will eventually be welcomed into the
Disney Princess Hall of Fame but for now
the ice Queen's status is pending Elsa
is king Agner and Queen I Dunas
firstborn daughter making her the
heiress of arendelle while she may be a
wonderful ruler Elsa's got a secret that
could ruin her life
[Music]
after letting the cat out of the bag
Elsa fleece her kingdom leaving her
younger sister Anna in charge however on
a had little interest in ruling
arendelle without her sister by her side
Elsa eventually comes home and takes her
rightful seat on the throne Queen Elsa
has no intention on getting married
anytime soon but that doesn't stop her
from ruling arendelle like the Royal she
is after all Elsa's royal bloodline
speaks for itself
Anna much like her big sister Elsa Ana's
princess status is also pending but we
have no doubt that the arendelle sisters
will make their way into the Disney Hall
of Fame in the nick of time
Anna is king a ganar and queen Dunas
youngest daughter making her the second
in command although she may never become
the primary ruler of arendelle that
doesn't make Anna any less of a princess
Hana might come off as shy and clumsy at
first but the young princess is actually
super brave and giving without her love
and dedication arendelle might have
never seen their rightful ruler take a
seat on her throne Anna is a
natural-born princess which makes
Kristoff a prince by marriage like it so
there you have it
Prince Anna is a royal by birth and
always will be melody much like her
mother Ariel melody is a very special
Disney princess after all she's the
product of a mermaid falling in love
with the human Melody's story can be
found in the Little Mermaid to return to
the sea which tells the tale of Melody's
upbringing despite wanting nothing more
than to go into the ocean Ariel forbids
her daughter from entering the sea and
chooses to hide her fishy pasts from her
that everything changes when melody
finds out the truth for herself
melody is Ariel and Prince Eric's only
daughter making her a princess by two
royal connections she's half mermaid and
half human and let's face it not many
Disney Princesses can say the same
jasmine jasmine is the sixth official
Disney princess to join the Hall of Fame
and she's one of the most beloved
characters of all time despite being of
age to get married Jasmine wants nothing
to do with her suitors and this has
everything to do with the fact that she
likes adventure and spontaneity after
escaping the palace walls in meeting
Aladdin Jasmine falls in love with
someone she'll never be allowed to marry
this is because she's the daughter of
the Sultan of Agrabah and she's expected
to marry a prince with a legitimate
royal connection Jasmine's disdain for
Prince Ali shifts when she realizes that
he's not who he's pretending to be
jasmine is a true born royal but she
ends up marrying a common peasant
despite her father's wishes
I choose you the Arabian princess ends
up making a royal out of Aladdin when
she says I do Belle Belle was a smart
and brave young woman who is nothing
more than a commoner she's the daughter
of a whacky inventor and she wouldn't
change that for the world
when it comes to being a princess Belle
doesn't have a drop of royal blood
running through her veins but that never
stopped her from joining the official
Disney Princess lineup Belle's big heart
causes her to become the Beast prisoner
but sooner than later she realizes that
there's a lot more to beast than meets
the eye
before long the Beauty and the Beast end
up falling in love and tempting the
hands of fate
Bal is the perfect example of a Disney
princess who is royal by marriage and
nothing else
Moana Moana is the daughter of chief
Dewey making her a princess by
birthright
she's a brave and just ruler which is
why her parents are certain that she'll
make a great chief when she comes of age
well we should clear the disease trees
and we will start a new Grove there
Moana is a new-age princess which means
that getting married by the end of her
movie isn't a must the young ruler
embarks on a life-changing journey that
ends up restoring the world's resources
and saving her people she's an official
Disney princess who is royal by blood
and not by marriage for now she is one
legitimate royal connection but all that
can change in the years to come
Moana is an inspiration and she's
allowed her people to reconnect with her
ancestors roots rapunzel rapunzel is a
special Disney princess for more than
one reason not only was she born with
special abilities but she was also
kidnapped at birth and held captive for
18 years she's a princess by birthright
and once she realized this there was no
stopping her after defeating Mother
Gothel Rapunzel reunites with her family
afterward she is finally able to become
the princess she was always meant to be
did Rapunzel and I ever get married
although she may be a royal by birth
Rapunzel is not a royal by marriage
after all she does end up with Eugene an
ex-convict Jane we all know that Jane
isn't a natural-born princess but did
you know that she's a legitimate
princess by marriage it was confirmed
that Tarzan is Queen Elsa and Princess
Ana's a long-lost brother
which makes him a prince by birth funny
enough Tarzan was adopted by kala and
Kerchak
who happened to be royal gorillas this
makes Tarzan a royal member of the
animal kingdom so we're sure that Jane
and Tarzan would be surprised to find
out that Tarzan is a prince by birth and
not only by adoption Tarzan literally
swept Jane off her feet when they first
met
[Music]
so much so that she ended up leaving her
entire life behind to be with him so
there you have it Jane is a princess by
marriage on two separate accounts while
she may be an excluded princess it's
only a matter of time before she joins
the ranks which Disney Princess is your
favorite let us know who your top three
are in the comment section below and
that's the end of our video thanks for
watching and see you next time on two
things
[Music]